got a news flash for you bozos the card
game is back on sale oh my God the
original edition of the card game some
of our favorite questions right here got
about 50 or so of them sold a bunch of
them put them on the shelf for a little
while now we're doing one final run of
the original series one last job baby
it's a good good time to get hammered
with your friends and find out at the
people that you know and that you love
are garbage so do yourself a favor the
link is in the description pick up a
pack today because they're gonna go
quick oh yeah and that ain't it tubby we
got Road dates baby we got two shows in
Atlanta coming up in November then we're
going to Charlotte North Carolina if
you're in the area get those tickets for
that we got two in Philly that are sold
out we got one left in Providence Rhode
Island those tickies are moving we got
one left in Boston that is for sure
gonna sell out get those tickets we won
a party see you there gang this episode
is brought to you by established titles
I don't know if you knew this or not but
if you own land in Scotland you become a
lord or a lady isn't it and that's what
we got in the business of baby by real
estate we bought just one square foot of
land over there
and now we're Lords yeah guys class up
your place a little bit you could become
a landowner with every order not only do
you become a lord or a lady established
titles plants a tree and works with
global Charities to support Global
reforestation efforts title packs give
you at least one square foot of
dedicated land on private estate in
edelston Scotland an official
certificate with a Crest there it is hit
it uh your certificate has a plot number
so you can see the location of your land
it makes a great last minute gift for
loved ones it adds fun don't give
somebody a sweater or a tie or a pair of
socks Jazz it up a little bit make
somebody a lord or a lady buy real
estate baby uh you can officially change
your name to order lady if you want to
you can put in your credit cards your
plane tickets whatever you want Daddy I
love it established titles is uh uh
actually running an early Black Friday
sale plus if you use the code garbage
you get additional 10 off go to
establishtitles.com garbage to get your
gifts now and help support the show
thanks let's go welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah a little
shall we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find it out the group
to be classy just a big old piece of
trash I'm your host Dave trolley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're down
here at antuti's basement she's upstairs
just got into a fist fight with the
neighbors kid oh no waiting to see what
happens with that my co-host is coming
at you from right next to me he is the
CEO of Ru garbage he is an international
businessman he is not to be trifled with
in the Board Room or the bedroom give it
up for KJ Kevin James Ryan Hey gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure your rape if you subscribe on
iTunes full video available on YouTube
as you know those numbers are cooking
closing a hundred thousand event let's
get it over to hump and then obviously
the greatest website of all time
patreon.com
[Applause]
and how about a nice quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good works the
ones and twos he crosses the t's he dots
the eyes give it up for T-Bone McMuffin
Toby McMullen everybody what's up
everybody yeah we got a fun one in here
we got this guy came in hot and I like
it it's called T-Bone a dirty hippie I
like it taking shots early gang the long
hair ain't lying because we could not be
more excited to have our incredibly and
I mean incredibly special guests here
with us today for the first time he is a
legendary stand-up comedian actor and
podcaster and you might have I've never
done I've never done a special it
doesn't matter I know Legend yes you are
as I was saying you may have seen him in
but not limited to gang sit tight
because it's a long one we got arless we
got Harold and Kumar we got Curb Your
Enthusiasm American Dad Pineapple
Express Paul Family Guy The Dictator
Arrested Development the league The
Comedians Alone Together 10 episodes of
Love on Netflix Oh Boy NCIS Inside Job
10 episodes at
splitting up together 25 episodes of
that nature can't do 11 episodes go [ __ ]
yourself how about that I got 10
episodes of Magnum PI reservation dogs I
got The Tonight Show with Jay Leno live
at Gotham your mom's house WTF The Joe
Rogan Experience kill Tony Chelsea
Lately 60 episodes at ah
I got at midnight hot ones this is not
happening The Comedy Jam something's
Burning Lights Out with David Spade the
cabin and of course he is an original
cast member of Mad TV did 166 episodes
on that groundbreaking goddamn
television show and of course he's the
host of tigerbelly and the co-host of
bad friends but the big question
everybody's mind today is he garbage
he's dressed like an a r man or a
homeless guy and he's got two Vapes with
them ladies and gentlemen and he's
dipping
ladies and gentlemen the one the only
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
first of all can I say this okay this
guy's whacking let me tell you something
let me tell you something half that [ __ ]
that you just [ __ ] rattled up bro
right I'm Japanese businessman
businessman number three I have no line
you're in it baby
I'm from a tree from some western or
something man I got there's they don't
have I don't have good roles listen yeah
we don't kiss ass we give credit credits
do yeah you're a legendary comedian and
actor can I tell you why I'm here sure
the reason I didn't know you had hippies
here I apologize for that I should I
should have warned you Mr Lee I love
platoon I love I'm telling you right now
my favorite movie James Phillips now
full metal jacket right I'm Pro Vietnam
War dude all right it's the one where
Asians we won yeah and you guys lost
with that you guys [ __ ] lost that
thing man my dad was in nam you son of a
[ __ ] we could hide in a tree for three
weeks with one banana and survive who do
you think taught them that we did it
shout out to the Red Coach I'm not a
deadhead right I don't believe in
flowers in the inside the muzzle of a
gun or nothing like that bro but you
know I'm gonna give you a shot all right
it's good to meet you thank you thank
you dog hey dude look at this I love it
it's all love over here guys the reason
why I'm with you guys is because I was
in LA one night and um yeah it's a very
cool night for us who's the guy that you
were with Jeremiah
Watkins
get out of here and you got and then
Whitney called me and said you got to
meet these guys they're the best oh
thanks shout out to Whitney can you come
and come and she uh and then then you
guys went to the diner and I went with
you guys well yeah which uh you know
just hit this on the check
did I really like that you tried to pay
this I tried I tried to pay try to pay
for everything yeah but you had three
ones in your wallet we already went over
this yeah yeah that was an open gesture
but we ate you know I thought there was
like camaraderie and there was of course
it was really yeah no it was awesome
yeah yeah and then um I thought you know
what I'm gonna [ __ ] with these guys man
I appreciate that and this is I've been
in I'm in New York for one week and
you're the only podcast I'm doing this
one
I like how he clapped after his speech
it was a good speech dude all right hold
on before I can't believe you didn't
have three different nicotine yeah let's
go in here you got dip going you got
your Xbox vape and whatever this thing
is so so chicken guy's got a lot going I
know what's the question
no you asked because I quit smoking um
seven months ago oh congrats yeah and it
was like I was I was coughing up blood
she's like purple blood like chunks of
it I should quit but you know I uh you
think yeah and so for four months I
didn't do anything but then I'm back to
like vaping and doing some Dippity Doo
okay what was your brand what cigarettes
were you supposed I love the yellow
American Spirits oh they're an
aristocrat okay yeah I'm high I'm high
level which I I mean when we were out uh
we went to a diner I don't know what's
the name of the Norms or it was normal
Norms Jonathan Norm's Diner uh you were
very you were like that you're like I
haven't been here in years that was
slumming it for you oh that's bottom of
the barrel yeah yeah we'll get into it I
was shocked I didn't know you were that
a little bit of a foodie kind of guy
kids Hollywood what are you talking
about
okay
it's fine I'm not you guys understand
him you might as well be the president
of Hollywood did you get that right
well I mean can I just ask you a
question then yeah right you know we're
not going to reveal this to your fans
and you're the people that listen to
this okay but you know you generate some
income sure from doing this podcast
homies yeah I've the only reason why I'm
here is because I've looked at your
numbers
right so I was like a straight shooter
right and I'm like okay they're [ __ ]
with the same kind of numbers I'm
[ __ ] with okay so that in my mind I'm
like you know oh they're making a
certain amount of money right and what
I'm saying is is that you're you can
afford sure good food yeah yeah we do it
and we do right but here's the thing
that's in the last six months oh all
right you've been eating in Chicago
since the 90s
yeah well the reason why is because in
my 20s I was so poor yeah of course
right and I was like um I lived with
nine people in a one bedroom apartment
in Silverlake okay when I first moved to
LA and
um my my roommate Callisto he's a
Mexican dude would be [ __ ] girls next
you know next door to me right I was an
incel by the way
involuntary celibate yeah I could not
even prostitutes would turn me down
really yeah I got here's 500
500. they won't even poke at it
they won't even flick it they wouldn't
flick it yeah I'll give you two to give
it a peek yeah yeah and in my early 20s
I want to get laid so badly but I
couldn't right and then I was just like
I eat to either shoot up a school or do
stand-up okay yeah yeah I'm like I'm
glad you found the comments there's two
robots right I was like I'll do stand up
right so you know but like you know and
then once you start I started doing
stand-up I slowly started getting
something sure and become kind of cool
you get some confidence I'm killing it
now you know what I mean
in case I have monkey pops
but obviously touched my face I'm never
watching myself yeah so uh what was like
oh yeah so I was very poor when I first
moved to LA and
um once I got my first check I was like
because we were eating BRC burritos from
El Pollo Loco and they're one dollar
what are what's BRC bean rice and cheese
okay right and they were 99 Cents and we
would share one a day share it with nine
years with three guys okay right my
brother lived with me too and we've
split it three ways right it got so bad
words like if you had like two extra
grain of rice you were fighting over
you're fighting over that [ __ ] it was
that bad and we would drink like you
know the faucet water and stuff and then
as soon as I got my first check I was
just like you know what I'm gonna go to
like not Morton's but it was like um
Ruth Chris I mean that was like the
first sure like this seems mid-range and
then um I started making money and
that's now I do that yeah you eat nice I
love that why can't I do that no you can
as an American citizen of course well
wait this is what that show this is what
the show was so we celebrate the guards
we also celebrate the wins the wins baby
like you know you you split a burrito
with nine guys for for three years
the first girl
I boink okay
this guy's striking out all over attack
hey I want to plow you the first girl if
sexually intercourse without paying for
it uh was I this is I was 23 years old
okay okay think about that yeah think
about that age I did stand up one night
and this girl there was no cell phones
at the time and there was this girl that
was at the show I used to emcee this
show at the comedy store in La Jolla I
love that room great room great room
best one of my favorite shows of all
time that's where I still box that's
where I started that's great that's a
great spot this is 1995. jeez that's
when I started
the door's locked you're well protected
don't worry anyway um there was no she
called me like I told him I was mopping
the club she goes hey can I talk to the
Asian guy that was like she called the
club because there's no cell phone
that's thirsty I like that and she gave
me her number did you pretend like you
were somebody else one second I'll get
Mr Lee hang on no no
no the manager answered okay I didn't do
that
Toby got that
got a heater going keep it in yeah I
like that and then I remember a week
later um
I was in her mom's closet with her what
in Oceanside and I was doing 69.
you know I've never done it before well
why are we in the closet I don't know
why but I was in her mom's closet and I
because her mom was home or something
but she was like downstairs anyway sure
at 69 and I remember her ass is like
this white Pure White shout out to it
when you he was winning you're winning
and I remember like tears coming down my
face
and I was like trembling and I was like
thank you Jesus you know I mean like all
from like dick jokes or whatever like
yeah yeah yeah it's crazy yeah it's
crazy so you know that was a long time
ago I mean but um I've been doing okay
since uh probably it's great 2 000. yeah
it's been uphill since 2000 man there
you go
um well take us back
is there a closet in here yeah uh hold
on before we get into that because he
did mention it it was uh I guess that
Mad TV check was probably your first
check like your first like big check no
it wasn't that good it was like um at
the time it was you know when you got a
TV show back in the 2000s and stuff if
you're on a network sitcom you would
probably get maybe your first job maybe
30 000 an episode that's a check but not
mad tv you got 4 500. and then everybody
takes like this right so your manager
your agent so you're making like 1200
bucks yeah something like that a week
yeah but still that's great
you you got your stand-up money which
back then it was 15 dollars a set
you know what I mean so you get three or
four sets with that you're like it's
crazy how little it's gone up over time
I was like 15 bucks pretty good
you weren't splitting bqe's or whatever
it was oh yeah no no after that now no
in fact I moved out of that house and I
got my own place but um was there any
dumb purchase you made early on we were
like ah [ __ ] I shouldn't have done that
jet skis something like that you're not
gonna believe the story but this is it's
a it's a fact
I um you're not gonna like it but I'm
sure we will I didn't have a car dude
okay right so my friend Aaron cater some
he's Palestinians fine he's not from
there but he's the guy I know I just
said that I know I just said I shouldn't
have said he was Palestine that was
weird he's still a good person yeah he's
a good guy I don't hold that again
just a regular comic let's say that
right yeah my friend Aaron regular comic
and um so like I never had a car right I
didn't know how to buy one so I go um I
went to Aaron he seems like he seemed
like a comic that had responsibilities
because he always were like Abercrombie
and finch he had khaki pants he was a
shirt Tucker you know this guy seems
smart it's not that smart right and I go
hey bud uh I don't know how to buy a car
he goes I know how and I go what do we
do he goes well you want to go to the
lot with me so um he goes I don't know
why he said this but he said pull out 20
grand
cash yeah really yeah so I did means
you're buying all right yes I'm gonna
buy it how many years in the Mad TV is
this
two years maybe two years you got 20 G's
but not no but no because at the second
year you negotiated was probably doing
well so yeah and then also I had booked
other things you know like I had done
Harold and Kumar I'd done other things
in between there so yeah a little bit of
cash that's a little cash so I go I
pulled out 20 grand what did you carry
the 20 grand to the brown paper bag
brown paper bag I remember that I like
how you got mad at the question to
realize how relevant it was a relevant
one yeah yeah hey do you know what you
know what just start over
Crosby Stills and that I love what else
I love Jerry Garcia
did she die right he died right Cherry
Garcia yeah yeah I love that I love Ben
and Jerry's yeah yeah this is my
favorite bit I [ __ ] ate hippies too
man do you really of course they sting I
know it's like they're grateful that
they I don't want to hear a jam in G
major for 45 [ __ ] minutes how about
two minute songs
anyway let's I got angry because my
friends used to go to the to follow them
in the 80s it was brutal I like the hits
though I like the Grateful Dead I'm sure
they got a couple of good tracks it
shouldn't be your personality that's
true so let's go back to my story yeah
so you got the 20 grand in a brown paper
bag you're out of key right so I he goes
I think the car I got a g um GTI
Volkswagen nice it's a good car it costs
like 22 Grand and I um I gave them Aaron
goes we have 20 grand in cash can we
just get it for that and he goes oh yeah
sure yeah yeah and I just remember
getting it damn man that's good what
color silver sticker automatic
but here's the story two weeks later
I step out outside of my house and it's
gone ah
so I didn't know that you could
call the police or go call like tow
truck service okay I just thought if
it's gone it's gone it's gone oh so you
just like walk to work no I bought
another one
same car yeah that's a [ __ ] bowler
move right that is pretty cool I'll give
you that let them take I think years
later I was talking to I think Rogan or
something like that you're like yeah
like on the patio of The Comedy Store I
was like hey just disappeared you know
that sucks they should have a hey there
should be a system he goes you didn't
call I thought no you yeah you can get
it
oh my God you didn't call your insurance
company no I didn't no I just I was so
embarrassed by it did you have insurance
I did no you have to have it okay yeah
yeah so anyway that's my first car thing
but oh wow so I learned I learned how to
do I don't know how to do like I just
learned how to do the time with the
sticks
do you mean like not digital like an
animal yeah I just literally I've never
heard refer to his time with the [ __ ]
yeah the sticks and I did that I learned
that I learned that but he looks like I
learned that seven months ago and Mark
Warren taught me is that you serious
yeah I swear to God like I don't know
how to do things Bobby is a very unique
man no that's all right when you say all
these things and all these things that
I've done it's like I don't even know
how any of it happened really sure yeah
I mean I mean because it didn't read the
sticks I just kind of show up and just
let things you know I mean I don't know
the lines I don't know what I'm playing
I don't know how I got it I'll tell you
how
wow you're extremely talented oh man you
guys got Moxie Kim how about that
established titles I'm a landowner baby
respect me as such Lord cue balls
now entering Lord cue ball in Lord Fatso
that's right baby we're landowners in
Scotland when you're a landowner you're
told you're called either a lord or a
lady and we're in because we got an
established titles and we got ourselves
just one square foot of land over there
that's all you need you don't need you
don't need Rolling Hills in a castle one
square foot of land get your lord yeah
it's a good time do yourself a favor
gang get on it and help preserve The
Woodlands over there in Scotland yeah
guys with every order established titles
plant a tree and works with global
charity support Global reforestation
efforts to give him back look at that
they're making you feel fancy and giving
back what more do you need that guys uh
your certificate has a plot number so
you can see the location of your land it
makes a great last minute gift for your
loved ones it's a fun it's a gag not gag
gift but it brings uh good energy to the
gift giving thing I I wear a cape and a
cloak and I gotta crown and everything
kick rocks buying a star uh get some get
some real estate baby I know that's what
we're talking about Buy Low sell High
officially change your name to Lord of
lady you can use that name on your
credit cards your plane tickets I know
what I'm doing and I had some classes
that dated to that Tinder profile of
yours guys it makes an amazing last
minute gift established titles is
actually running an early Black Friday
sale plus if you use the code garbage
you get an additional 10 off go to
establish titles.com to get your gifts
now and help support the channel do it
yeah okay let's talk about that butcher
box baby love that butcher box baby Best
In The Biz and Thanksgiving coming up
you want to have the best turkey
possible where you're gonna get that huh
the Pep Boys the grocery store no you
get it from butcher box free range
turkeys baby the most delicious turkey
you'll ever had you don't want to be
showing up to Thanksgiving like a bozo
then you got your aunt crying everyone's
eating the stuffing mashed potatoes are
getting thrown around do yourself a
favor this year this Thanksgiving get
your turkey from butcher box yeah guys
uh they got free-range turkey no
antibiotics no added hormones none of
HGH baby we're talking all natural you
don't want to be a bozo uh and also like
we've said every single time uh you get
what you want delivered right to your
doorstep they have free shipping in the
continental US no surprise fees choose
from a variety of a variety of box
option plans from curated to customize
change of plan whenever you want enjoy
high quality cuts that are hard to come
by at the grocery store at an amazing
value exclusive member deals save big on
your favorite cuts the whole nine yards
they got recipes guides tips hacks
whatever you want uh the main course for
Thanksgiving dinner can sometimes be the
main source of stress but not anymore
baby butcher boxes offering are you
garbage listeners a free turkey with
their first order so get in today I just
talked them up to giving it away sign up
today at butcherbox.com
ayg use code ayg to get one 10 to 14
pound turkey free in your first box
that's butcherbox.com ayg use code ayg
to claim and still do it yeah let's take
a step back let's go back let's go yeah
childhood where'd you grew up had you
grow up mom dad brothers sisters laying
on us what oh straighten your mic a
little bit sorry
bro you're so good I apologize for the
long hair we're good man I love you man
I don't know my therapist says that um
I can't believe you're alive I think you
know sure because you had a bumpy a
bumpy ride in the beginning right right
because when you grew up like the way I
did you know um you you you turn out a
certain way and I took all like my
defense mechanisms and my survival tools
and I use it to my advantage I mean to
make money okay and to have a career
right but if like I lived in Korea
I would just be like on opium probably
like you know and I'll probably be a koi
fish farmer or some weird [ __ ] like that
right or carrying rice okay yeah like I
would have no future sure but only in
this country I think you can return your
pain yeah harness it and and do
something good with it right so my dad
was uh where were you born
San Diego you're born in San Diego okay
I just remember like um being born and
then it just being really cold like the
feeling like even temperature wise I
don't know why because we lived in we've
moved to Minnesota right when I was born
really yeah so I we lived in Minnesota
there were no other Asians a diner in
Minnesota and like I was bullied you
know the kids would throw ice at my face
and go Eskimo you know what I mean she's
always like running from them and then
like I'd come home and my dad would be
like drunk and um he was very violent
you know what I mean and then like
um
like you would be able to beat up my mom
and stuff you know and um that she would
come into my room with no teeth and
bloody mouths yeah it was like pretty
crazy serious [ __ ] yeah serious and my
brother and I would just fart on each
other and like yeah there's a good bit
back then yeah
and like we would like show each other
our penises and like do like puppet
tricks with our yellow little yellow
penises they were like minions before
minions you know I mean like a little
yellow like yeah
you know you can't do that on live but
you know what I mean but we did it you
know amongst ourselves and then um
I guess there was this guy that had Down
syndrome down the street when we lived
in Minnesota and um he
he molested it so that was cool anyway
Good Times we're having good yeah did
you get out of Minnesota well I want to
talk about the molestation if I may sure
you're right ahead yeah um may I talk
about it please yeah yeah
um am I garbage yet
we don't know yet no but you are crazy
do you think I'm a crazy person no I
think you're uh no you're awesome you're
[ __ ] you're the best because I'm
gonna tell you something this is the
first time I've been on this podcast and
the next time I come on if I ever do
come on it'll be different yeah it does
because I'm just trying to like um funny
this is what it is we want to hear your
story I know but it's kind of like you
know when I guest star on like a TV show
you want to be as good as you can be so
you get invited back the next time I
come back it'll be 50 okay that's great
right now I'm nervous sure so it just
comes out like this because I really
want you guys to like me we love you I
know so and I want the hippie to like me
and I want your fans to like me so it's
coming out like our fans are all your
fans you're one of the most requested
guests put together you know we're in
this together yeah and I have to say as
a side note um for white guys you guys
have my body like my shape my
personality and it's not a good thing
for you it's really a good thing for you
but when I looked at you because you
look at Andrew Schultz and you look at
Stefano they're like human they're like
yeah yeah and they do they look not
mythological they look like they can
stick their penises in anything you know
I mean you guys look like in cells like
you guys look we do beat more penises no
one's in here my mother was a Minotaur
like I don't know anyone in La that even
has your Vibe sure maybe like there's
some homeless comedians
if you go to open mind late at night I
love how he's gonna be nice this episode
looks like because I feel the same sure
right I go I think that you guys are
white versions of me and that's why I'm
blessed to be here that's what I'm
saying yeah thank you thank you so much
for that wonderful wonderful because
because you guys I know you guys get you
have a girlfriend I have a wife you have
a wife you have a girlfriend girlfriend
right and that to me is like
mind-boggling it really is to me it's
like oh my God it does too yeah yeah it
works it's working that means you have
the humor goes a long way because those
guys to Stefano and Charlton these guys
right they have their looks to get them
by right anybody can get broads when you
look good right they were looking like
us but right with us dude it's like
we're like Miracles like we're like
killing the game right and we we're also
Paving the way for other uglies yeah
right so we we're storming the beaches
here yeah yeah and now let me say
something right if you lost weight yeah
you could have like a Gary Goldman Vibe
right but you
no shot
back to the mall of station why not
I should say that but please
yeah I don't am I being rude no oh my
God
it's yeah you're so good and so funny
that the fact of he's like yeah I gotta
be playing tonight but now we're making
fun of you I'm not gonna make fun of you
guys
crippled until we get 18 minutes and
he's like good night oh yeah yeah well
no uh that's I was just telling the
truth I think I'm not being mean we
don't think that
foreign
what did your mom and dad do for a
living what was your dad doing my dad
owned clothing stores called Fashion Gal
he owned them yeah and we owned um well
my uncle's and my dad owned like 75
stores across the country so he did well
yeah they did we did well I was doing
well yeah yeah but still with the booze
and the abuse and stuff like well he was
like he didn't obviously drink at work
but you know he would drive around at
the stores and this and that but he um
would come home and get drunk and then
like you know I would always like hide
in my room Jesus because you never knew
what what was gonna happen you know um
he turned into like you know Incredible
Hulk but he didn't grow like just and
he's yellow no yeah yeah he was a bad
guy he was a bad dude yeah and he would
pick up kitchen tables and throw it at
people was crazy jeez and so anyway and
then I was most about the guy with Down
Syndrome down the street that's what my
brother says my brother says that and
then um you blocked it out you don't
remember I think I I mean I think I
there's some imagery of the shack and I
and then Zamboni you know what Zamboni
is like the yeah yeah yeah he he took
care of the Zamboni in this outside ice
rink down the street from me yeah and um
I think he molested a bunch of kids but
I went there every day you know I mean
in the summer because he had candy I
love candy
you know I mean and so um I don't think
anything happened where like I think I
just jerked him off and I mean I stick
with my fingers in this um ass yeah yeah
his disfigured butthole
never forget it kid really likes the
Snickers huh
you know and so um and then I then we
moved to San Diego at the age of 11. for
business like it was like yeah my dad
goes let's move uh right yeah and then
we went to the family stayed together
he went with you to San Diego oh yeah no
this is oh he's always been there okay
yeah yeah and when we moved there it was
like it was the best because I saw
like dudes like Filipinos
my age with full-blown muscles and
statues at age 11 right they I had like
skater kids and like you know this is
back in the days where like Bones
Brigade and all these things back then
yeah coolest [ __ ] yeah and um I just
remember this kid like flipping over his
skateboard and like putting out a line
of meth Jesus across the street from me
and I went I didn't even ask what it was
I was like can I have some
right he's like yeah dude is that candy
yeah yeah and it would snort that and
then like you know I'm talking about 11
12. you're gonna be like young damn
is this just skating fast yeah yeah yeah
is this a nice neighborhood you guys
moved into yeah family had a little bit
of money you moved in yeah you're down
in San Diego you get a little bit more
of a wider cultural experience a little
bit more familiar yeah nobody nobody
grabbing at you [ __ ] like the
bullying was different not non-existent
right yeah
Multicultural yeah yeah and then I'm
sure Minnesota is different now but in
the in the 70s I don't know yeah yeah
for sure that makes total sense and then
my dad had this refrigerator where he
he'd stock alcohol you know I mean and
because he was an alcoholic and I could
sneak in there and drink as many beers
no one would know so it was it was just
start I just started my alcoholism in a
drug addiction that early early you know
and then um yeah I just got all F's okay
in school I was on the wrestling team
and tennis team there you go you have
any good yeah I'm pretty athletic you
know I mean but other than that like I
was just a failure you know I mean I
just you know and then every time you
would bring home like an F to your
violent Korean dad and your mom they
would get violent and crazy and it was
just like your brother good in school he
was up until his senior year and then he
kind of drifted but um yeah he was like
the Christian
you know he did he went to church and he
also you know got straight A's and then
I don't know what happened that's a
tough comparison because my brother was
really good in school and I was terrible
at school yeah and that just makes you
look you look even worse worse yeah it's
terrible you don't hate your brother no
I love them yeah I love my brother yeah
I love them 100 and then I went to
rehabs I just remember in um in high
school I did went to three two or three
like one detox two regular rehabs and
then I uh yeah and um nice ones though
out there McDonald's Center was the one
that got me you know in La Jolla okay
and that's where so that's where
see I believe um
I what's so funny I don't know you I
just just I love you yeah I believe that
nothing happens everything happens for a
reason huh okay and I believe in sort of
like this Cosmic thing where like it
just if you do make the right choices
that there's a path and things just fall
in line the way it's supposed to and I
don't fight it you know what I mean plus
when you're growing up in a you know
immigrant home you you there's no life
skills or you learn because I don't know
the Korean language my parents never
taught me anything about anything like
everything that I learned was through
like Scorsese movies or whatever you
know I mean like Mean Streets you know I
mean like I would rent movies and watch
them so it's like I had no life skills
so like when I went to that rehab when
my junior year in high school McDonald's
Center that's where I kind of learn how
to live you know I mean and learn things
and I learned that you know things
kind of happen for a reason and then I'm
supposed to be at that rehab and I just
kind of bought into all that right so
it's like so I I went to rehab in La
Jolla I got sober in La Jolla I grew up
in a town called Poway which is like 45
minutes away right so all every a
meeting I went to was in La Jolla now
what's in La Jolla The Comedy Store
there you go so after high school I
moved to La Jolla because that's where
all my sober friends were and I started
working there and I happened to have a
job
at a coffee shop that was attached to
The Comedy Store the one that you went
to yeah it used to be a place called
disc Cafe it was owned by 91x radio
which was like the alternative station
and I had orange hair like I bleached my
hair you know I was really into like
the early Sonic Youth and yeah the
fugazi yeah yeah
yeah sub pop [ __ ] right and I just
remember getting change because we would
need to get change from The Comedy Store
you know for the coffee shop and so I
met Fred Burns at the time was the
manager of the La Jolla comedy store and
then the girl that I was working with at
this Cafe her boyfriend was a guy named
Mike Carano who was the manager of the
Pacific Beach Improv who still works for
the Improv now damn so you you have to
imagine I'm in La Jolla and I'm
surrounded by comedy indirectly right
because Mike would go hey after shift
we're gonna go see Brian Regan at PB
improv and I would go I'd see Pop cat
gold with and I was really like
and I would like to stand up when I
would watch it yeah but I wasn't like
speaking to it it wasn't like pulling
you right it's until I saw like an open
mic where I was like I can do that yeah
yeah you see you see someone do do it
back [ __ ] better than this idiot yeah
yeah so I just remember like um this
Cafe closing I'm still sober so I got
sober at 17 and then I'm 23 years old
now living La Jolla working like
restaurant jobs and [ __ ] my coffee shop
job closed and I was walking by the
lawyer commissary and they happened to
have a help wanted sign him and I
knocked on the door because I knew Fred
and I go hey dude I'm the guy next door
he's like oh yeah no you know I go can I
get a job he's like well I only hire
stand-ups
and I was like well I'm thinking about
doing it which I don't know if I was or
not and I got a job there's a bar back
and then two weeks later I was on stage
that's [ __ ] awesome yeah so that's
how it and it happened quick for me
like I did it three months later
um Carlos Mencia you know him yes
you like him he's a good friend yeah no
I I don't know him but yeah I know who
he is who is he uh he's a guy he used to
work with hey you really got me in the
hot seat here from The Vibes you're
giving it's a guy you don't like I love
him yeah okay he's like a bro he's dude
I wouldn't be here without him and
Paulie Shore sure so I'm just asking you
no he's my friend how do you feel about
him uh
he's the guy who does the compilations
of jokes right
that was rude
[Music]
you dirty hippie son of a [ __ ] true but
[ __ ] you no so um but do you like what's
your what's your feeling toward it uh I
knew of him before I got into comedy so
I didn't understand all of the other
rules and all of that kind of stuff yeah
so I before my time yeah I don't have
any real uh understand or any of any
skin in the game or really know what
happened right I have some I have to say
one thing about him one of the best
performers I've ever seen he's surprised
yeah I mean he was a murder machine of
course you know and that's all I have to
say Kimmy how about that display baby
you mean a coolest In The Biz yeah he
was something cool to cover up your
walls don't use a paper poster that's
not gonna hold up what is this the 1990s
get yourself this plate baby they got
cool designs they got movies they got
Anime they got cartoons and they got
licensing deals with Marvel Star Wars
the whole nine yards and Netflix and
more yeah baby I'm talking heavy bike
none of that [ __ ] that rips or bends or
crinkles oh you could eat off this thing
I'm turning mine into a goddamn coffee
table uh it only takes 20 seconds to
hang at this plate no power tools are
needed no damages no frustrations I'm a
Seinfeld man myself that's what I dabble
in with everyone that you buy display
plants a tree as well because they're
giving back to the world that's
companies these days that's what this
Plate's doing they're putting it back in
the putting it back in Mother Earth baby
uh so you're not only getting cool walls
your support Mother Earth think about
that nice uh click the link in the
description to see some of our favorite
disc plates and save up to 29 get 25 off
when you buy one or two or 29 off when
you buy three or more get one for you
get one for the kids got one for the
basement get one for the bar in the
garage get one for anywhere baby
discounts will automatically be applied
to your cart when you click the link or
use the code Garbage When you visit
displate.com that's display.com code
garbage or click the link in the show
notes do it okay let's talk about
manscape baby and skate come on you know
what we're talking about gang just
because Summer's over don't mean you
don't stop cutting the grass you I'm
saying keep things trim keep things
tight maybe a little bit of that holiday
candy gets sweet on you you know what
I'm saying that's when you gotta this is
when people let it go you got to be
better than competition keep it and with
the Platinum package you can take care
of downstairs and you can take care of
the attic too because there's nothing
worse than seeing a good looking dude
running around with nose hair sticking
out everywhere take a couple of seconds
get the Platinum package and clean
yourself up yeah guys it's got the
lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer and a weed
whacker nose and ear hair trimmer that I
use on my butthole both are waterproof
so you can shave in the shower or to
pull whatever you want to do with the
Ultra Premium body wash and Ultra
Premium two in one shampoo and
conditioner you'll have your skin and
hair feeling hydrated smelling fresh
get your [ __ ] together be a little bit
of a gentle listen we're all dirt bags
in our own right tighten it up a little
bit with manscape they're even throwing
two free gifts you get the manscape
boxers which I love by the way and the
shed travel bag which I also use the
Platinum package 4.0 covers all your
bases from head to toe here we go here's
the turkey get 20 off and free shipping
with code garbage at manscape.com that's
20 off plus free shipping with the code
garbage at manscape.com manscaped clear
out the leaves it's your tree trunks
time to shine yeah but anyway so when I
was there Fred would have me host the um
Saturday night show okay one show if
you're a doorman there there was a rule
that you get to do five minutes so you
have to imagine like I was just chomping
at the pits because you would have
Hollywood guys come down there and
headline so as soon as Mencia went up
his manager was there sign me 45 minutes
and then Paulie was there five minutes
she got signed well he's just like I'm
you know I'll like you there's a term
back then like I'm not gonna give you a
contract but I'll like think about you
you know I mean and if that something
comes my way I'll help you and then
Paulie was just saw me and he was just
like open for me so like I think within
a year of doing stand up so I was 23 I
was I did I went up and opened for
Paulie in Vegas jeez in front of like 5
000 seats I only had like five minutes
right and I went up there and his mom
was there and his mom made me a regular
at all right so it's like yeah it
happened kind of fast so it's like I was
like oh I went from the street to
Knocking on that door but that's the
thing I was saying that I believe all of
those things rehab to all those things
were just I'm just kind of waking up and
just showing up to things you know you
have to show up to things and you have
to try right but those are the only two
rules that I've literally gone by it's
like I try and I wake up and I show up
and let's just see what happens right so
it's like I've only so I have no little
skill set or people got your talented I
don't know I guess but I'm just doing it
sure right and so that's my kind of like
philosophy that's your view on it yeah
so I just kind of like started doing
this and then all of a sudden I'm like
here like that's why I'm right here
because I just kind of I'm following
this path yeah I kind of flow going with
the flow but I'd like gone in and out of
you know sobriety since you know so I
you know I had 12 years
17 years of sobriety
and then now only have seven months okay
well hey baby back on the horse going
with the flow I love it oh in high
school I suck dick I forgot to tell you
that to go back there was no
zip fiction like a Pulp Fiction podcast
where we're just doing pulp fictiony
kind of a thing so you go through the
flow of the universe
you blew a couple of guys yeah you can't
tell time yeah yeah
I'm not gay I'm not gay I'm not gay but
I just did it yeah yeah because all my
people suck dick that aren't you yeah
I'm like open to like like you know
let's try it you know what I mean you're
like I don't like it you know what I
mean but then you try a couple times
anyway
flow of the universe okay but the reason
why I talk about showing up let's go but
did we can I touch please yeah the
reason why um I love New York so bad I
love it so much I mean and bad is that
um
you know when I started doing comedy I
was kind of like I was doing like Dad
jokes and like you know like pause more
positive you know what I mean and
um I remember coming to New York and I
had to play a club Pauline for Caroline
Caroline yeah
what are you looking at nothing he's
looking at the camera nope there's a
sound it's the elevator yeah yeah yeah
but you've never heard a sound before
Bobby check in it's a podcast yeah I'm
because I'm trying to give um
New York it's props okay right many many
years ago I did Caroline's and I could
only do like 20 minutes after Mad TV and
they're like you could headline but I
could I only can do 20 minutes sure so
and I remember like no one like it was
hard to sell tickets you know and so
they made me go on Opie and Anthony yeah
and and I was the first time I went on
that was terrible but I remember
learning how to do this kind of new
brand of being more honest open and be
open and all that kind of stuff so I
learned that through you know seeing
Geraldo and uh Patrice and Norton and
all those boss
and open Anthony and those guys kind of
taught me how to like defend myself the
reason why I'm mean
I was saying that you guys look ugly and
this and that wasn't that's not my
nature of you saying that yeah thanks
for bringing it back up yeah no it I
think you know New York comedy kind of
brought that out of me you know that's
great it fits more my personality brand
and my personality but it's like and I
feel way more comfortable being evil but
it's like you know
um but I learned that through being here
in this town I love this town man you
know it's a great City yeah but it's a
great question I think I talk too much
so why don't you guys talking no you're
the guest on a podcast I'll be back
we're gonna catch you smoke so is there
other questions yeah of course we
haven't even scratched the surface that
was that was a great back story
um it was a good origin School Story
fantastic pretty good yeah yeah and it
makes me lovely even more to be honest
with you man and you deserve everything
I'm still on the fence a little bit but
that's just me Bobby I don't think so
I'm in the Bobby pool yeah yeah yeah
we're together dude yeah all right so
just to go back a little bit what was
the name of the uh the street that you
grew up in Minnesota soda what was it
what was the name of that Dover drive
it's not bad nice house
um yeah Edina you know upper middle
class do they still own the stores or is
that all is that oh they went bankrupt
it's gone it's all gone well they're
dead both your parents passed away no my
mom's still alive your mom's still my
dad died okay
score one for the good guys are you
close to your mom what are you close to
your mom yeah yeah but she's annoying
but I love her is she out in California
with you no she's in Phoenix she's in
Phoenix Arizona yeah it's weird because
my interject her yeah please please
um you know my dad died you know and um
two years ago and that's when my I
relapsed after 17 years of sobriety [ __ ]
yeah and um
and then after he died all this Asian
hate started happening like you know
stopped Asian hey right and like um
people were getting targeted occasions
right elderly
that's why I wish my dad was still alive
imagine that someone just run up and I
would like I would like drop him off at
our Trump rally
right right and then they would all you
know American flags would be great all
they see is a silver GTI streaking away
um I just threw in a stand-up joke
that's a good stream thank you thank you
tonight but thank you a great bit but so
um so my mom so imagine my dad died two
years ago and she my mom
you know was beaten by this man
for forever and um he dies and now she's
the freest person well that's that's
what I've ever seen like she's just like
doing her thing that's awesome right and
just like
um all that bad because you know he was
sick for like 15 years
she had to like dig the [ __ ] out of his
ass he was had strokes and he was
paralyzed and so he she became his nurse
yeah I mean for all these years and we
would go back there and like help this
guy right I love him but because he had
changed you know as we got older but um
so it's just really interesting to see
my mom so free that's really cool that's
awesome yeah anyway that's fantastic all
right talk about the flow of the
universe right now that's fantastic
staying in the childhood of any pets
growing up ah don't get there oh that's
well that's the button that pushes
become molested on a Zamboni yeah yeah
don't go there man I can't talk about a
fish tank what are we doing here well I
mean the truth is is this
um you know do you know how many animals
I have now no that's also a follow-up
four dogs nice and three cats nice
they're in my freezer I'm gonna have a
Barbie girl
no I have four dogs here I have four
dogs and three cats and another stand-up
truck I just throw them no it's great
it's killing yeah but I have yeah and I
the reason why I have so many animals is
because of my parents I um
this is a sad story but um why are you
laughing I'm preparing for it yeah if
there's no like harshness to it they
didn't kill it but um I remember asking
my
um parents when I was young I go I was
like eight or nine I go can we get a pet
and so my parents go oh we'll get a cat
so I had this cat Tommy we got got Tommy
as a kitten okay and he was never
allowed in the house so in the garage I
had like this pen you know what I mean
and every day for like a summer
that's all I did was I was in this pen
and I would play with Tommy and I love
this cat so [ __ ] much man
so much man like it was like that's all
I could think about you know I bonded
with this thing
and then one day like
I go out there and he's gone I freak the
[ __ ] out
I go outside you know I mean I'm running
around the neighborhood
so finally I'm like crying to my parents
go Tommy I can't find him right and my
dad goes well we gave him away
cry you know what I mean I go but what
about he's like there was like no
compromise there was no discussion mommy
allergic right
and then like they both went in the
house
everyone just being in the garage like
Not only was I sad but I was just like
full of Rage [ __ ] yeah right like rage
like like you know not only were they
like ethnic and from immigrants and
stuff they were just like no discussion
about anything no no sharing of feelings
like how do you feel what can we do very
old school very old school right it's
just like my way the highway
and that I mean with all the [ __ ] that I
went through like all those little
events kind of made me like you know
very angry and rageful and like I think
rightly so yeah I think that's a lot of
displaced emotion sitting somewhere I
think that helps with stand up I think
that feeling of like I'll show you
yeah you know that's always like when a
girl rejects you like I will show you
when a guy bullies you you'll see what I
I'm gonna do and like you just kind of
do things like you go crazy and do
things that are scary because you're
just trying to express yourself and get
you know get all that out yeah I mean
and it like I said it before like all
that stuff I used as a tool to like you
know rise yeah I mean a lot of kids like
will you know not get sober I think that
also comes into play for me like I was
always kind of like you know if I
continue to do drugs and become a thief
and go down this path I'll end up more
like my dad or end up like a criminal so
I'm just kind of like you know I gotta
get sober and do the right thing because
I always believed like I was always a
good kid my brother and I are good kids
you know we were like we were always
empathetic and and and
um so you know I just kind of use that
anger and that rage to um benefit myself
but anyway you know because my dad
parents did that I um they did that and
then when I was 15 we got a dog and then
they gave that dog to a pool our pool
guy the guy that cleaned our swimming
pools gave your [ __ ] dog away yeah
yeah dead dog so the same but at that
point I did I knew something was going
to happen so I didn't bond
defend yourself a little bit and then
10 years ago I met kalila my
ex-girlfriend
and um she was really into animals and I
remember going to her apartment I met
her on Tinder and she lived in Long
Beach and I remember the first night I
spent the night at our house there was a
kitten that she found on the street Ming
I still have Ming and Ming was
underneath the couch because he was kind
of feral
and then one day
um she was going out of town she goes
can Ming
stay at your house condo in Hollywood
so I go yeah yeah and I and I remember
coming home from a spot
and I opened the door and Ming was just
kind of waiting for me
you know at my doorway that'll melt your
heart yeah and then goes fine
like that's what it sounded like where
are you right I just remember like Ming
sleeping on my shoulder yeah and I just
remember going thinking to my side God
this is who I am
like this is I love animals that's great
I forgot right and then I just because
you were hurt yeah and I just became an
animal hoarder
like my house is like you know because
we also we constantly Foster
too so we always have like there's a
rottweil downstairs there's a [ __ ]
pitbull downstairs right so I'm
constantly like you know open to all
animals right yeah there's that thing I
I adopted a dog about six months ago and
there's that thing of like I didn't have
one for like 20 years and I'm like I
forgot you forget what you were the
unconditional love that you were missing
out on you're like ah this is all right
you know what I mean yeah I'm allowed to
smile and have a good time over here I
just gave it away why
would you have an animal uh we have a
cat yeah yeah I love oh look come on
what are you nuts laid on traffic for
those what I know me too it's
unbelievable it's like um it just makes
life like Fuller yeah yeah right really
does cats dogs I've never gone through
as an adult the death either I think
about it I think about it daily I'm like
this is gonna [ __ ] suck seven deaths
that's got bodies on seven deaths I
gotta go through
uh because I I'm connected to all of
them yeah like right so I'm like like I
have written down at home like how old
they are I also Google always how long
they live you know what I mean like I
have it all [ __ ] playing I'm gonna be
[ __ ] yeah yeah it's a as a kid you
know not that the you know the pain of
having them the pain of the unknowing of
oh my God what happened to Tommy is
[ __ ] brutal then it's brutal when
your parents say we gave it away that's
so definitive but as a kid a lot of
people don't think about this we will
get married they get a dog or they get a
cat then they have kids when those kids
are about 10 11 years old that dog's
gonna die that's what happened to us we
had a German shepherd and one he he got
real so you were born with a German
Shepherd in your life yeah and so he's
your life yeah and we went to football
practice one day and we can't and my mom
picked us up she was balling crying
she's like she's like Mike's gone and
dude we were [ __ ] up brutal
brutal it's absolutely brutal so good
luck with that
let me ask you something go ahead
did you immediately cry
um yeah 100 yeah as a little kid yeah
[ __ ] freaked out for how long uh I
mean
I mean theoretically probably a
therapist would say I'm still not over
it
yeah yeah that's why I stopped going
um yeah no for days for weeks months
yeah yeah it kind of lingers with you
100 but I'm sure that gives you a better
understanding about
death no or no made me scream even more
scared yeah well you didn't process any
of them but you should have talked to
somebody somebody should process
somebody should have guided you want my
goddamn dog back and somebody find Tommy
too will you yeah yeah Jesus Christ me
and Mike are out there [ __ ] knocking
over a bank probably did you guys
immediately get another dog or was that
it didn't get a dog probably for five
years after that all right I feel like
you got to fill it back in quick to like
okay because it over I feel yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh hey I'm gonna put my
attention here and I'll tell you this
just as a different Road traveled so
when we got when we moved we were like
all right they were ready to get another
dog we got a dog he was a maniac Tyler
he was a Vizsla Hound
um and my parents kind of got fed up
with them and they took them back to the
SPCA but my dad literally went and he's
like I'm not doing this and went the
next day and got him back he's like
we're not giving we're not we're not
we're not we're not we're not we're not
doing that wow yeah yeah yeah wow so um
you had a good childhood then you had a
good childhood wow yeah it was all right
yeah you yeah pretty good it's good
I would also say this probably wasn't
great either but just give me a second
just give me a second I'm just trying to
get the rosette mentioned there mine was
a little dysfunctional that if it makes
you feel any better there was a
um an activity center that I used to go
to when I was a kid where I'm pretty
sure
Zamboni got him yeah yeah
that's scary yeah like I have nightmares
of like this guy with Down Syndrome on a
zambonia yeah I'm just running on Ice
mine wasn't candy it was hot dogs what
you got me with hot dogs yeah is that I
was just saying is that code for like
his dick or okay until I get him to the
show he gets three hot dogs a day
wow so you had did you what again we get
their hands on you Kippy no not that I
remember unless of yours I completely
repressed it yeah yeah I repressed it
pretty hard and I'm not 100 sure what
but I remember seeing an adult penis at
that place yeah when I don't think I
should have yeah yeah yeah plus it was a
weird class that I didn't know I was in
I mean I mean I just feel like that just
happened that's happened since the
history of time 100 yeah of course yeah
yeah I mean I'm cavemen probably did it
yeah there's a percentage of people that
just get God man that's what it is I
probably smelled okay just imagine a
cave game
right right and he's just like jerking
the kid I mean yeah no candy either okay
yeah a couple of rocks right or
something a couple of rocks in a dark
room
that's how you get so they got him in
the Vans lion meat Hey kid you like
giraffes get over here
uh let's talk a little bit about now uh
what's your favorite flavor Gatorade
I know
you don't drink Gatorade no what do you
drink during throughout the day just
water water just water yeah you you
would say you're a refined individual
now I know you like to eat good food
well I mean I drink like Diet Coke okay
okay here are the drinks I drink here we
go all right I want to get into it this
is exactly what the show is all right
water okay right Diet Coke DC some sort
of cold brew or four four shots of
espresso over ice I like that they also
pronounce it espresso just letting you
know
espresso there's no X espresso there you
go okay thank you four shots is a lot
too but I like it is there any milk in
there oat milk do oat milk don't do that
again what don't correct me again I
didn't correct you I just pointed out
that you pronounced it yeah it makes me
angry
anyway
um I drink those and then um
that's it
sometimes I'll go to like fancy
restaurant go make me a mocktail
mocktails are nice big mocktail yeah
yeah they'll do something Fancy with
ginger or you know something sure uh so
you do go out to a nicer as you know you
go out to a nice restaurant uh will you
order the sparkling water or you get
still do you do like the pellets give it
a bottle of Pellegrino yeah I never get
the tap
yeah I always get bottled always always
get bottled although I heard New York
water's great I like New York tap but
yeah I'll do tap water pretty much
anywhere yeah for the most part but in
some places you can't and then like in
the Philippines you're not you can't I
was just in the Philippines three weeks
ago nice right and you can't drink that
water yeah you get diarrhea but um how
was the food good
why pollute
you did you know what it is now you know
what balut is look it up I don't even
know how to spell it b-a-l-u-t I don't
think it's Pizza it's not street food
fertilized developing egg embryos
there's a picture of Bobby with two
thumbs up look at that that's a bird all
right so what they do is they'll boil a
duck egg right maybe two days before it
hatches that's a hatchable egg right and
so it's it's you eat that so I had one
how was that well when you when you so
when you crunch down on the skull the
brain squirts in your mouth
and then you get the feather stuck
between your teeth but other than that
[Laughter]
so like yeah that's what you want your
first time having it yeah I I yeah
because I known about you know so it
wasn't good
well honestly if I closed my eyes and I
just ate it I just like oh is this egg
but like you know I mean with more
dryness you know what I mean to it you
know but when you when you have eyeballs
right like this yeah and you look at it
it's just like it's weird because the
eyes are there and it looks at you like
yeah two days buddy what about like two
days like when people's looking at you
yeah all right what about lumpier Taro
okay yeah yeah I had that too but um are
you an adventurous eater like will you
do the wacky kind of what are you
talking about maybe that was just maybe
you lost a bet he didn't see this over
here
um
I think I'll try something once like I I
won't eat monkey brain or anything like
that that's weird but how many of the
eggs did you eat just one six pack well
I did it on camera on my podcast so it's
like okay it was the show okay like if
it wasn't taped maybe I would have maybe
passed gotcha okay fair enough but I'll
go to a country and I'll eat something
some of the yeah the delicacy that they
have but like I would never eat like
like you know like I wouldn't never go
to the yulin dog eating Festival okay
would you go there no I would yeah would
you get angry yes yeah [ __ ] freak out
I'd freak the [ __ ] out probably end up
getting yeah I don't know yeah and in
Peru this is gonna Boggle your mind they
used to have a cat eating festival and
but they would have an arena I'm not
kidding you and you would they would let
these cats you know out and they'd be
running and I think you chase them and
stuff it's like a game they make it into
a game yikes [ __ ] up but I wouldn't
eat that [ __ ] but I would um in fact I
think when I make
if I have like 30 million dollars
in the bank I want to quit comedy and
I'm going to um I'm telling God this I
want to Manifest this
I'm going to go to Every like dog eat
eating and cat eating anything and I'm
gonna put all my resources into shutting
it down it's good there you go it makes
me crazy very Humane yeah but that's
never gonna happen
never say never you can manifest that we
can't manifest it but yeah
all right so we did the animals what
else the eating
um what do you got let's get into the
let's get into why I would be garbage
like the things that I do because like
when you say garbage right that means
that like I do garbage Behavior so I've
done many garbage Behavior sure
we're starting to creep there a little
bit I [ __ ] so many people over I'm a
liar all that stuff
I'm a liar no I mean is that what
garbage means no what does garbage mean
it doesn't mean criminal yeah oh yeah
yeah no I mean I've never murdered
anybody but I'm just like
oh okay we're getting there okay good
we're getting there have you ever been
to a gender reveal party
what was that where they reveal the
gender of the baby the baby what's like
blue smoke or red smoke pink smoke no I
I've only been invited to you know get
invited to a lot of parties no I've only
been invited to
one
two weddings really really in my whole
lifetime what I've never been and then
also any of my good friends that get
kids I never meet the kids and I never
meet that I don't see them you've only
been to two weddings yeah I mean that's
trash is that good that's bad what do
you mean you don't get invited to a
wedding oh no I think because people
don't think I'm gonna go
okay like I built this reputation for
myself and you can ask people that I
don't call people back
I don't text people back I'm kind of
hard to get a hold of real Hollywood I
like that no it's not Hollywood it's
just my way makes me feel better because
you called me pretty cool no I know well
no because you're you've caught me in a
transition yeah okay you've caught me in
a transition where um it's like those
wedding invitations out folks yeah I'm
trying to do something yes Bobby's got
30 million in them you know I'm trying
to do everything it's very good yeah
yeah I'm I text everyone back I um I
show up to things that have you know
because usually you know I used to be
like I'm not doing it whatever if it's a
stand-up gig or if it's like a job or
you know an audition I'll show up to
those but if it's like a personal thing
and if you know I'm just like a social
thing yeah yeah and it's out of fear
it's not a because I don't want to be
intimate with people and this and that
but I'm like do last year or two I've
been kind of like going against you know
I mean
and it's been working it's working
that's right well we appreciate you
coming we appreciate it yeah thanks man
do you like sloppy joes
I do I like barbecue I like sloppy joes
um the the but the Buns have to be
toasted okay that's classy yeah um I
like it when there's not a lot like a
pickle
you like a pickle yeah like a little bit
of coleslaw a little bit of pickle in
there coleslaw means warm yeah I mean I
like it sliced I like it in the silver
wrapping okay but I'm sloppy joe all the
all day yeah yeah that's a guts yeah
very good very good I've ever played
racquetball
tennis player not racquetball no tennis
very crazy ever been on a softball team
no but I just did a softball movie where
um
I did just literally two months we
wrapped okay and I played softball for
the first time for a whole month that's
pretty cool because I was doing Softball
comedy coming out yeah it was it's nice
I know if it's good or not but it's got
a good cast it's got oh okay tell what
do you mean why yes of course so it's
got me the fat guy what's his name Mo
Amber nice you fat right good guy though
very good guy yeah he's getting a Black
Adam it's coming out I can't wait to see
it
and um so happy for his success
great guy I love mobile and we're very
talented all right Johnny Knoxville nice
I'm familiar yeah it's got um
other people oh Theo Von there you go
cool you know him yeah he's good and
then um
it's got the um Brian Van Holt he's a he
used to he's an old actor he's very
talented he's got some rappers Gator
um
um a guy named Shakewell oh another
rapper dumbfounded have you ever been in
a focus group
no no no no okay I've been like um but
I've been like the subject of focus
groups sure why on the shows oh yeah of
course yeah you have to do um
you have to test like they test of
course right and they do focus groups
and you know what I love about being
like like with the way I look and I have
a round flat face you know what I mean
and I kind of look like if you don't
know my history like
you know I like if you know it like you
know like oh my God you know he's
adorable he's adorable he likes he looks
like an emoji you're right yeah and so I
love getting on a sitcom because I know
I'm gonna test time right so it's like I
always get like I did this uh one show
where they were like yeah you tested
higher than babies and monkeys
I'm like that's good right like it's
unbelievable like they don't have like a
meter to even like go there right that's
awesome it's awesome so it's like and
then they're always like you know um
they pick it up because like we got like
you know a baby monkey yeah we have the
cutest man alive yeah yeah and that's
why like Ken Jung probably does baby
monkey numbers yeah yeah baby yeah
uh do you fly first class
I won't get on a plane if it's not yeah
we just started yeah business-wise yeah
personally I do business really personal
advice we can't we can't swing it
personally I can't I I know your numbers
you can no I can't listen this is what I
say I can make the purchase I can't
afford it does that make sense
I shouldn't be but I am oh can I say let
me say something to you sure positive
wise right
and I'm this is not a joke like I my
I've been gone I haven't been home in a
month and a half I went from the
Philippines
Hawaii
to Canada to here New York right my
agents and my managers like don't pod
you're gonna lose your voice just do
your jobs come home take a rest and I
said I have to do are you garbage oh
thanks
and I'll tell you the reason why okay is
because
it's you guys are legitimately On The
Rise you know you guys have a great
reputation in La every comic that I know
knows you you guys and so so when you
guys say like I don't know you know if I
can afford this and that it's [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] and I'm not buying into it
because I'll show you my bank now that's
all right well you're probably spending
on like Fentanyl and or whatever I don't
know what you do on the side but I'm
just saying we're gonna have to borrow
money yeah you can afford it you can
afford what's going on yeah so I do like
if you can't fly like went to the
Philippines you have to do business
class yeah well like right I mean I just
did the the lay Flats on to Europe and
back and that was the first that was a
game changer it's a game changer right
so you can go into your bag sleep yeah
right right before that I had like four
flights that week before that and then
where I was coming back we were going to
Vegas it was just like it's like you
gotta you gotta rest when you're
traveling that much right right right so
um welcome guys thank you you guys are
doing well and it's like let me say
something it's no there's no shame in
saying that we you know you know because
I wasn't able to do I've been in this
business since 95 I think the first 20
years of my career I didn't do it 100
yeah I did middle seat Southwest even
when I was doing the road it's only in
this aren't you that guy from Mad TV
yeah and I'll still do it you know I
mean because I think in the last
five or six years you know I'm 51 right
I've been great thanks man and so you
know I think I'm like you know what I
can do this and I'm gonna allow myself
to have this I worked hard of course
don't feel bad about it no yeah I don't
no not at all I just would I just wish
is new to us I just got my passport last
year wow late last year and you just
traveled for the first time to Europe
yeah how was it that was unbelievable
went to Paris wow for work no he went on
his own Justin with your girl yeah oh my
God and then isn't it weird yeah it's
great it's great right yeah it's crazy
it's so crazy it's so like really cool
it's so cool and let me ask you
something do you think that America is
the best country in the world
Toby get this commie out of my studio
God damn right it is
[Laughter]
people are better over there I'll tell
you that no I understand my cowboy boots
what's this guy talking about the
quality control from what I experienced
in Paris is superior to what we're doing
here
America is a great country
I'm an American through and through I
[ __ ] red blood red white and blood yeah
right no right red white and blue that's
thermal that's what I want to say let me
see that line again sure I'm an American
citizen I'm proud of being American yes
sir I [ __ ] red white and blue good right
yeah
and I'm gonna and and uh and
and I really believe that America is
probably one of the best countries in
the world sure but you're not allowed to
say if you're an American to say America
is the best country in the world unless
you've been to another country I I I
agree but look at all these [ __ ]
people that live in the woods
and I'm not blaming anybody sure and I'm
not you know talking down to anybody
right but there are aspects to other
countries right food you know I mean
their educational system and this is
that that are strong you know their
their medical system you know what I
mean and so it's all right to give props
to other what other countries are doing
are doing well right so I'm saying it's
like we're great right you know it's
argue we can argue if it is the greatest
or whatever but I'm saying it's up there
baby you know if you've never been to
another country it's like shut the [ __ ]
up yeah and shout out to the French man
they know their way around a [ __ ]
steak frites I can tell you that
um all right let's say in travel a bit
do you have name brand luggage
like is to me yeah yeah that's up there
I don't have time
yeah I have some to me yeah yeah tumi's
good yeah you do the hard challenge oh
yeah I do hardships for sure yeah how
are you getting around the city taking
the subway you're taking Ubers I've
never been on a subway never been on the
subway no are you taking Uber
um blacks Uber blacks or just regular
with black drivers no black cars
I do the one that's like the most
whatever the closest thing is okay
sometimes it's like luxury I'll do that
if it's close closer yeah okay it feels
like they've been real wonky the past
few months it's really horrible yeah for
me it's more time than quality I gotcha
that makes sense okay all right yeah
I'll just go in a really raggedy taxi I
don't give a [ __ ] yeah you do first
class flights what about the hotel you
like to stay at a nice hotel
yeah I mean come on baby I mean like for
me it's like I need room service uh-huh
well you go hang will you go heavy on
room service like just have a taste or
whatever a little taste of this
well I get what I want okay is that what
you mean yeah like if I go I like this
side like if I look at the appetizer
menu I go I want this that I can't just
I'll get all three yeah that's what I
love yeah yeah yeah and then if like
um if it's like hey we got a what A5
Wagyu steak from Japan like at boa
there's in La there's this wagyu snow I
don't forget what it's called but Snow
Pea or something like that but it's
wagyu A5 and for I'm not kidding you
a strip of steak this big is 200 Jesus
I've had it get it let's go you've
earned it baby you've earned it in your
apartment now are there any hotel robes
or slippers or in your homes oh no Thief
man
I don't I'm not Thief you're allowed to
take them they're not if you pay for
them
the hotel towels and all that stuff is
the hotels yeah but they'll charge you
for them you're essentially paying them
on the back end oh oh you do yeah if you
leave with them do you use I've stolen
pillows they charged me wait
you've stolen pillows from a hotel like
two of them why it's got nine hair
dryers in his house I'm not a thief
though no because sometimes I like okay
of ironing boards and I'm gonna take a
plan so I'll just bring the pillows on
or whatever or I'll stuck them in my big
backpack wait a minute okay hold on hold
on a second there is another trashiest
answer we've ever back this up are you
telling me that you're walking onto a
plane holding a regular bed pillow Hotel
I've done that yeah yeah
holy [ __ ]
um if you go to a restaurant could I
make an announcement please
so I was in a relationship for 10 years
and um you know I'm single
and um
you know the DMS and stuff like I like
the nude photos right you hear that guys
but guys guys any Zamboni drivers out
there every other one is a dick pic
and I'm tired of them guys lay off the
dick pics for Mr Bobby Lee because it's
like they're bigger I get it
they're bigger and I I know what you
guys are going like hey you know man I'm
poor but I have a bigger dick right sure
but I get it it's enough okay right for
you ladies out there right if you want
to send them I'm not against it right
but now I know that when I make this
announcement there's gonna be a plethora
of Dick Pics Now sure because they're
gonna go against you know I mean my but
I'm back I can't get on my knees but
I'll do it like this yeah please no more
I beg of you
you want the ladies to know that Bobby's
open for business yeah I mean I'm not
like you know a [ __ ] right
um you know I I'm dabbling around you
know it's good
um good for you but I'm dabbling around
um I'm a little picky okay as you should
be I think I should be sure but
um you know um I like personalities as
well you know what I mean but you know I
like beautiful faces you know I like
your New Yorker like some of you New
Yorkers I like you the girls have
beautiful faces but their hands are like
coal miner yeah yeah right and they have
a voice like hey how you doing you know
me or whatever I don't know what to do
in New York but you know what I mean
okay what do you mean duly noted well
I'm just saying you wouldn't have said
any of that if you'd seen our analytics
that's where about seven percent of the
audience
um how many suits do you own and do you
know how to tie a tie
I know how to tie Thai and I just got my
first suit
um what I got my first suit four months
ago the reason why is because
um I went to Eric Griffin's wedding and
I borrowed my friend Gene hongsu and I
had to tape the so there was electrical
tape in the in the in the sleeves why
didn't you go get a nice suit for you I
don't know how I didn't know how just
listen to me man
right so and then I was at the wedding
and right and I had electrical tape
right and then I went to another
friend's wedding so I've been to a
couple hours live okay lately I've been
going to win it and um and I had
electrical tape and people were like
starting making fun of me and stuff so I
was invited to my first real Hollywood
Premiere a Premiere that I wasn't I
wasn't in the movie I just know the
director and it's like a high elevated
thing and so I just kept calling
comments like where do I go and I just
went to a mall and went to a Hugo Boss
sure and I got altered and so I had my
first like real legit
um Premiere and I look good nice and it
was like I went home and returned it no
okay I have a hung I have yeah I can't
wait to use it again yeah it looks good
it's got like a bluish dark blue dark
blue eyes vibe to it yeah right now yeah
yeah I like it very good that's pretty
good
that's pretty good uh but the movie I
went to was nope
I do that I don't want to say anything
we talked about that yeah yeah yeah we
talked about that at norms now I know
Eric might be a little bit different
because he he's a peer but what did you
give as a gift at that wedding
foreign
nothing you didn't give a gift you
didn't give a gift
what if you went to like a non
entertainment they came to our wedding
no gift no gift why
I'm not in the mafia
no it's like what you would have an
envelope put in this bag yeah with some
cash in it
listen if you're
poor uh-huh like if I knew a guy that
worked at Subway okay
which I would love to meet somebody from
there sure I mean I'm not I'm not
against it yeah
but and I knew like you know that
they're struggling you know what I mean
but like I went to Sebastian
maniscalco's wedding sure that's what I
didn't bring
[ __ ] really he's a [ __ ] millionaire
I'm not gonna go and give him a vase oh
he's a vase or like no I showed up
that's the nice [ __ ] that's the gesture
yeah you know I mean I go
congratulations you know I mean I say
all that whatever you need to say I mean
I'm so happy for your future yeah or
whatever you say okay and I sat there
the whole time and I clapped and I cried
I dealt this [ __ ] okay right Eric no
he's a comic he's fine he's doing fine
okay you know I mean I went to Delia's
wedding okay all right he's fine okay
are you leaving
she's leaving we're in the middle of
work what are you talking about where
are you going
he's just Jason
garbage meter
just got your first suit never you don't
give gifts at a wedding stealing the
pillows from the hotel okay do have a
Tumi though that's pretty nice anything
else about the restaurants yeah uh say
you go out to a restaurant with the with
friends right say you and Santino or so
going out to a nice din-in I have a
thing who's picking up that chick
well Santina and I'm gonna say that I'm
gonna start a war and he's gonna be so
mad
but he I'm beginning to think let's uh
he disappeared I want to say that the
last meals he disappears really so right
before the check appears he goes I got a
golf thing or you know I mean oh [ __ ] I
gotta go to Dave was like you didn't say
you were gonna shoot today right there's
something and then he leaves and then
the check comes and it's happened for
the last eight times
and I I've never said it out loud before
I don't know if that's gonna start
something with him he's paid before I
remember a call I'm sure I'm sure you
know but the last guy he's a nice guy I
love a very talented guy but the last
couple has been a little suspect but you
know I'm gonna wait for the next meal
see what happens you know okay and let
me say the last one was maestros
it's a very expensive restaurant chain I
think I spent I'll just tell you what I
spent because it was with please do the
producer Andrew and a girl named jetsky
who's like a sidekick on bad friends
very talented girl she had never been to
a fancy restaurant so we took her
maestros and I think I dropped 750
dollars
and he left
really right and it was kind of you know
it kind of irked me a bit you know I
mean I'm now expressing that and don't
edit that out I want to see what that
happens for a relationship edit that out
it's the clip what are you talking about
yeah yeah I want to see what that
happens okay I gotta say he's not cheap
he's been he's saved my life a bunch of
times and I love him he put this in the
clip too keep this in the clip too he's
a great guy right but I'm just saying
last couple times that's all I mean I
say this I gotta call ball I love you I
gotta call brawls and Strikes yeah
750 bucks we dropped that yeah you got
to be dropping are you kidding me dinner
I know a nice restaurant you think I
should be paying for it um that's a
haircut to you guys who gives a [ __ ]
that's getting coffee you come in here
all that that's what you hit me with
750. I got Tom Segura back here with a
52 000 check not included wait wait wait
wait wait wait that's his check that's
what he spent on his uh his birthday
dinner
all right so here's the deal about Tom
Segura right
can I say something about Thompson girl
have you had him out here we had that
was that's him he wrote that greatest
guy right love him love him the greatest
guy in the world but you know it's like
I never doesn't do stand up
ever I've never seen what the clubs are
not that right and I don't watch anybody
you know I mean I don't know what
anyone's doing he murders he's one of
the best I've ever seen yeah he killed
yeah he's one of the best and that's not
what I'm saying yeah let me follow this
logic follow this logic right so he's
just like he's like hey you want to do
shows with me in Canada this is last
week I saw you were yeah yeah that's
right so I'm like oh [ __ ] that's right
and I show up
and it's like stadiums yeah
he ain't doing the [ __ ] yuck
he's huge he's great like I still play
like [ __ ] you know I mean Wise Guys
and sure you know yeah we were just a
great club right yeah I'll do the car
you know uh the Denver Comedy Works
great clubs great clowns but he's
like he's you too yeah
it's crazy you're right principally 750
I should just eat that seven right
you're right I [ __ ] up right but
here's a little thing you're talking
about flying first class just killing
pillows and complain about 750 at a
dinner for a team but here's the deal
trash he spends out of McDonald's
and I will again yeah yeah but here's my
rule and you and people know this about
me
if I pay for it
you don't get to take nothing home
bobby gets the leftovers I don't take it
home either what do you do with it we
leave it on the table yeah
I forget that just we leave it you're
not a leftovers guy I'm not leftovers
guy and I I hate when people start
packing it up like I'm gonna take this
home
are you paying for it I I know you're
not gonna I um the logic is this I agree
with you here's a lot I agree here's the
logic it's like I'm anti-leftovers yeah
I'm anti-lefters also you know I've I've
gone to dinner with you know struggling
comedians I've paid for the dinner right
and they just make this assumption that
they can just so like we'll get this
wrapped up and it's just like I don't
know what it is about me it's just like
no you have to leave it I respect this
where you come you're like this is what
I'm paying for I'm not paying for your
lunch tomorrow yeah and it feels weird
saying it now first of for the first
time I get it though you're right but I
have a lot of weird rules that's a rule
the Assumption I don't like the
Assumption so if you were out with a
couple struggling Comics Bobby you care
if I take this home no you would say no
no absolutely no you appreciate asking I
appreciate you asked okay but you're not
unless did you pay for it it's mine
this guy's crazy and I love it
is he mine I pay for it I'm letting you
eat it
at the table sure
yeah okay that's it I'm with it right
that is my thing okay you know what I
mean um what's the reasoning that you
like to leave it is it a is it a not a
power play
but is it well for me it's like I don't
take it home because I've taken it home
before I just don't eat it sure okay
right it just stays in my refrigerator
for like a year right and they're like
spagos why is this it's been a year ago
and like I don't like it's just gross
right
and so
I
don't know I don't know if she's
I did it with a couple of dates recently
where you let them take it well yeah
yeah because you don't know you don't
want to look weird yeah it was hard to
do they're like can I take this I was
like yeah okay listen 13.95 he gets all
yours I know it's wrong but the there is
a not a power a power play is not the
right word but but there is a a good
feeling of you know
well we didn't finish it don't worry
about it just leave it here it's fine we
ate what we wanted we you know that we
had the experience of the dinner the to
me the dinner together with the people
is when I saw that first once I was
[ __ ] when I first started comedy I
was waiting tables in Philly Jamie Foxx
was filming a movie and he came in and
they ordered like four different things
and he only had a little bit of each one
yeah I was like God damn that's [ __ ]
classy and he didn't take it home no
yeah I finished it in the back
yeah he was not kidding no are you being
kidding so you know what's Jimmy's [ __ ]
yeah Jamie Foxx the seafood burrito yeah
yeah
and here's another deal is that I worked
at a restaurant as well for years called
the Brockton Villa it's in La Jolla and
I remember
um you know we would take you know the
bus boys other people take people's
steaks and meet and bring it to their
dogs and stuff right it's not going to
waste yeah that makes sense yeah yeah
for sure I would just crush it I need to
get more tip out of my bag go right
ahead
take your time I will Talk Amongst
ourselves this guy's crazy right
all right where were we before we hop
back in uh
well here's the deal I want to talk
about
if you have any more questions number
one number two I want to talk about um
have I reached the threshold like in
terms of like if this is the line how
close to the line I am to pass to get to
garbage you're you're
a trash you're yeah you're you're into
garbage for sure I wouldn't say that a
hundred percent just yet you're starting
to reveal some things that's leading me
to believe that however the 750 thing
would be one but not taking the
leftovers we've we've reached the
conclusion here on the podcast from
doing it for the for the last couple of
years that not taking leftovers is a
classy move okay it's wasteful we get it
it's wasteful I get that but I also come
from the thing of if I order something I
eat it whether all of it or I don't like
it then I'm not going to take it home
but yes I'm anti-left I'm going to tell
you one story and to prove that I'm a
garbage person okay okay well let me
assist before you tell the story just
just to stay in the restaurant when you
get appetizers do you share them with
the table or oh yeah oh no I'm like you
can eat off my plate okay oh like it
yeah like you get everything number one
ladies out there you'll ladies out there
check it out
you you you will we're a wing man in
this guy you will never
pay for a meal again nice ever like that
right I like that you want to Uber to my
house I pay for that right it's an Uber
pool but right
okay that's a trick yeah you're right I
do do that
I'm kidding save me eight boxes I don't
even know what that is but my point is
having a quick stop and Reseda real
quick yeah so you'll never do that right
um you if you need even a little bit of
help I help yeah I'm in so I'm like the
best you're a great guy great you're
right a big heart but here's I don't
like needy okay I don't like needy like
I don't like you know you gotta check in
with me every day well you're out
no I feel like if we're like if I look
at you your little eyes and like little
I like big eyes too but like what are
your eyes and I go listen I'm not gonna
cheat on you when monogamous but like
you're not a parole officer I'm not
gonna check in you know I mean like I
mean I'm busy trust here yeah we're
trust let's trust each other just don't
cheat on me I don't cheat on you yeah
right when I'm in town we'll hang out
with cuddle whatever right but I don't
need like you know uh you know I'm not
when it comes to a life partner I don't
want to be enmeshed with somebody 24 7.
it just drives me [ __ ] crazy also I
refuse to give up video games I will
play it as long as I want to it when a
Hogwarts Legacy comes out and when
Starfield comes out I'm gonna play that
[ __ ] 16 hours a day and there's nothing
you can do about it you're a big video
game guy I love it I love it how many
systems do you have several of them I
have all the systems I've switched off
and I will play as long as I want I'll
give a [ __ ] you have a gaming chair yeah
full with the speakers and the whole
thing I mean I have a whole gaming um
situation and I like I go to this
situation I play Destiny I play on Call
of Duty Warzone I play Star 2 values
farming simulators I like RPGs I like
all of them the farming simulators are
very classy yeah you have no idea what
you're [ __ ] talking about and in fact
you know what dude you're a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] because I'm gonna tell you
something right now stardew Valley is
the great one of the greatest games ever
[ __ ] made in fact in a lot a lot of
[ __ ] critics and stuff will say it's
probably one of the top 10 games in the
last decade ever made and it's
independent game made by um um Eric
Barone he did it right he did it on his
own and it's a [ __ ] Masterpiece so go
[ __ ] yourself
how are you with the tip you a good
Tipper I I go 30 off you go 30. yeah
yeah I go 30.
he's coming back he's going back and
forth here yeah um have you ever had a
subscription to maximum magazine
no I have the internet why would I okay
that's pre-internet though do you ever
buy girls going wild
what do you have girls yeah yeah yeah I
mean I dude I mean come on I'm complex
when it comes to that kind of stuff man
okay you know I mean my [ __ ] goes deep
you know like I I listen I'm not gonna
name when I watch yeah you don't need to
you on the internet but like you know
nothing illegal but like you know I mean
you know I mean I've gone wild do you
work just asking do you work alone Bobby
oh yeah you do work alone yeah I'm fancy
with that [ __ ] really you like it what
do you do I'll go to La labo and drop
some cash on yeah see he's like he's got
that yeah he's got that classy Vibe too
in fact I got like this is not an
exaggeration you can ask kalila I have
probably
300 bottles because during the pandemic
you couldn't go to a store right so I
would just kind of like Google the best
you know I mean uh relevant um colognes
for men in like France or different
countries and I would just buy them just
without even smelling them I would read
the description Oaky you know what I
mean Cutting Edge Euro right right so I
would just I would just get them shipped
and I would spray it smell like I don't
like that
[Laughter]
well you know Koreans don't need
deodorant and that's a fact you Google
it you don't use deodorant Koreans don't
have Bo huh it's something that's like
about our
um genealogy or whatever okay we don't
have the glands and stuff so we don't
I've never even seen what I mean I've
seen them at the store but I've never
opened one up and smelled it all right I
don't even know how to put it on no
deodorant doesn't need deodorant I gotta
say that's pretty classy did you ever
did you Google it uh yeah this is crazy
uh there's like you have a gene that
doesn't uh you don't smell you Korean
dude saving money on deodorant your
whole life that's pretty [ __ ] like I
could like run
A Thousand Miles right not shower for a
month and my pits wouldn't smell just
like nothing hmm
would you eat a hard-boiled egg in
public
yeah why it just ate a [ __ ] head yeah
yeah yeah
um how do you feel about the rotisserie
chicken from a supermarket
I've done it yeah I'll get the whole
chicken I'll I'll pick it and I'll put
it in tortilla oh that's pretty cool put
it in there you'll warm up to tortilla
oh well there's a microwave like yeah
but still that's that's
um I like um deep dish pizza too you
like to eat dish pizza oh yeah yeah okay
if you had a choice between oyster
crackers or Saltines what are you going
with oyster you're going oyster yeah
that's your answer what's your favorite
deep dish pizza
well um here's the deal in La you know
obviously we're in LA right so there's
not like we don't have Chicago or you
know I mean right so like you know I'll
get a place called Blackbird there's a
um most Masa in Echo Park has one
there's one called Hollywood
um Pizza on Pico that's pretty good but
so but then I'll um when I go to Chicago
I'll do all the lou Malnati right and
I'll do all the other one you know the
fancy ones he knows his [ __ ] yeah yeah
I'll eat those you know okay yeah will
you fart in an Uber
oh dude I I almost got fired for from a
TV show because I farted
I farted did I tell you this
I had to get a lawyer I was on the TV
show
it's a fact
Kevin Costner did not appreciate it so I
wonder I was at Mad TV I had to get a
lawyer one day I showed up there and um
went to the rehearsal room and there was
a girl I'd never seen her before I know
her now but trust me but um I've never
seen her before and she was sitting
there eating yogurt
it takes a young girl and I don't know
why I was so tired like six in the
morning because we had to rehearsal so
early
I just I had a fart so I I grabbed the
back of her head and I farted in her
face
and she had her mouth open and then when
I did it she started crying
and then so this guy Ron Peterson who's
a Canadian actor he runs across this
rehearsal Hall to physically assault me
right because she's crying what did I do
you know that I just farted in her face
right and um
and then I remember Mike McDonald who
played Stuart on the show put him in a
rear naked choke hold it was dragging
about it was chaos I love Mike McDonald
right and then and then they were like
and then they were like go home to me
and I go well who is she anyway she's a
new actress when we hired as a regular
on my TV I didn't know he farted but it
was crystal Flynn again we're best
friends now but um it took a while for
her
so would I fart an Uber I'll fart
anywhere yeah I'll fart in your face
uh uh okay
when was the last time you wore pajama
pants or slippers in public
I've never wore pajama pants before okay
because I sleep naked and then um
slippers all the time like you mean like
you mean like sliders
no because slippers are intended just to
stay in the house or ones that made a
continent yeah right never never no but
I wear sliders and I even wear like um
um girly things you know I mean like if
my girls like she has some slides that
are pink and fluorescent I don't give a
[ __ ] yeah fluid yeah can I tell you the
story now or oh please God I'm sorry go
right ahead
do you know Eleanor Kerrigan yes
you like her
yeah yes I don't like how you tell
stories yeah that's right you make me
choose sides but we do like girls
exactly because life is a war yeah her
face I'll choke you out Bobby comedy is
a war and I have to know where you
[ __ ] know we love her I can't wait to
have her on the show you've never had
her no she's the best just never the
best
um but Eleanor and I are friends now but
we hated each other for 20 years
it got to the point where
like I wouldn't even show up at a club
if she was there really yeah like she
was we just
this our smells annoyed each other I
mean like if I she had a nine o'clock
spot at a ten o'clock spot and she had
left if I could smell her it would make
me want to vomit I [ __ ] hated her
but it was my fault the reason why and
I'll tell you why and this is the story
what if this doesn't make you you make
me a garbage person I don't know what it
is
so many years ago we had a manager at
The Comedy Store in Hollywood and he was
named it was Kirk and he was Thai
and from Thailand like he was like Thai
general or something
and he was like you know if you'll show
up to you know one minute late you'll
buy it you know you do 10 seconds over
your time one day you die you spy I'll
kill you you know like he was the
[ __ ] everyone hated this guy right
everyone like he made life there
miserable right but here's the deal
because he was Thai and because I wasn't
getting spots right he was my Ally
right okay so every time I would be
working there as a doorman because
before I think it's about there for like
a year as soon as he came it's like hey
you want to go up like he was that guy
with me yeah I could show up 20 minutes
late
because we're at the Asian thing sure
right it's the best right
and so they made it they made he made
life there so horrible the waitress were
quitting people weren't even calling
response so about 300 people
signed a [ __ ] secret
document document with signatures to get
this guy fired Jesus and they were gonna
[ __ ] and so Paulie loved him because
this guy Kirk raised Paulie uh right so
Paulie had no and the shores had no idea
about this thing
but I found out right about it
and I went to the top
and I ratted
300 people out
whoa right I go yeah no they're doing
this [ __ ] they're doing this thing
man right to the top
everyone got ripped you know what I mean
like I [ __ ] this whole thing up
everyone hated me I was the most biggest
weasel yeah you just yeah you just I
lost 300 enemies yeah and everyone hated
me
so am I garbage now
uh I mean you were garbage before that I
feel if we're being honest you're not to
be trusted I can tell you that no I'm an
electrical tape in the sleeves of the
suit was a real bad look for me to be
honest with you
um I'll tell you why I did that and you
guys I understand why I don't think you
do it's not because I'm a rat no why
then why did why did I do it because you
wanted to succeed
what you wanted to succeed in comedy
yeah and I'm gonna tell everyone in
there like I was right
screams at me I was then right and then
it goes down the barrel of his camera my
white friend you're absolutely right but
I have to say something to your fans
okay right now all right sure this is
that I would never do that if I work for
the government I would never do that
I'm never gonna work for the government
okay but if let's suppose he gave me
they gave me a position right right what
would you like Secretary of State what
do you have to be [ __ ] a senator that
could be a possibility true you might be
able to run it yeah right right like a
state representative right so you know I
would never do that in any other
circumstances in fact I'm a good guy
when it comes to rats and all that stuff
right I completely understand that yeah
but if you [ __ ] with Stage time
I I draw no I mean I go all the way all
bets are off all bets are off because
it's like it's my only Lifeline for a
life sure it's my only Lifeline to make
money it's my only my it's my dream
right and I feel like when it comes to
my dream right I would I mean I would
never kill anybody or you know I mean or
get somebody killed or anything like
that you know I mean like human
trafficking all that kind of stuff like
I would never do stuff like that but
when I'm I mean what kind of stage time
is this
but but I will like I'll lie I'll lie
sure right I mean I'll call people out
I'll start some Wars right to get some
stage time yeah I heard Marin bumped you
and you put them in a shipping container
yeah yeah I do that woke up in Bangkok
giving hand jobs out I get that
especially as at a younger you know this
was a while ago I presume right
that was that what happened 20 years ago
yeah yeah so at that point 25 years ago
which is Last Summer
I needed spots in the belly room uh for
The Listener who doesn't understand when
you're when you're starting out in
comedy it's brutal it's scary you think
every single part we were just talking
about this you think every single person
is your enemy and if one person gets
your competition if one person gets
something that means you don't get
something it's a very narrow scared
petrified world view of Life yeah
I also want to say this okay and this
just came to my mind sure and I need to
say it okay
and I'm not saying this in a negative
way but I just want to look in the
camera and Joe Coy will know shout out
to Joe Corbin a joke but I'm talking
about like the Ronnie Chang's right the
Ali Wongs hear me out some of them
negative
I love those guys I love them I love
them right you know these the younger
generations of Asians right they came
and they know this right they came in
was not the 90s when I started sure of
course it was infinitely more racist I
was the only one that my type doing it
sure you could count in one hand across
the country
that were Asian doing amount of
successful Asian Community I would have
[ __ ] like at open mics in the 90s
people go I'm not putting you up because
Asians aren't funny
like legitimately that would be the
thing right it would be so brutal so you
have to understand in that environment
right what does one do sure right I have
to survive
100. man I'm gonna win right and all the
you know Ally and all these young Comics
have come to me and go you know thank
you for Paving the way they've said that
I mean Ali put me did a paragraph on me
in one of her books about what you know
how nice isn't that right I'm not a bad
guy I'm just saying that like dude I had
to [ __ ] you know what I mean me and
Joe Coy had to survive playing the win
not that Joe I don't know what Joe did
to survive but I just remember in 97
when I met him he was like the only one
doing it right and him and I that's why
we bonded Steve burnt I knew back then
because when I did The Tonight Show he
called me out of the he searched my
number down he goes [ __ ] another Korean
dude doing it I mean it was like we were
desperate to like find each other sure
right so it's like kind of you verse
everybody mentality yeah I had to do it
and I you know I I don't feel you know
bad about some of the things I've done
you know I mean you know um you took
them all down I like it yeah I'm winning
now Bobby yeah I will I you know
everybody loves you I'll light a win
yeah yeah
I lie all the time yeah I love it my
name's not even Kevin yeah
what else huh I gotta be garbage yeah so
I've already I've already did it right
hmm yeah didn't that didn't help your
case was last time you had a massage
Bobby
I don't like it you don't like it I
don't like when people touch my body
what about uh the nails the man I have
here have you ever had a manicure they
look good are they Manny yeah it's nice
that's good no it's class that's good
you need that that's in your favor
uh do you have a shoes bye let me
explain man
[Laughter]
creature you want to talk about icebox
anyway my buggy iPhone uh-huh right yeah
yeah they can get bigger I'll scare you
I want to work together with Bobby and
take you down yeah you're trying to are
you trying to Edge me out here Bobby is
that what you're doing no being single
at 51 you just want to be able to like
you know present yourself in a certain
way of course
doing things that are different that's
all I love it okay fair enough we love
it uh do you have a shoes off household
shoes off or shoes on
well I have different levels in my house
like most most people when they come to
my house only stay at the bottom level
no one gets to go up the second level so
really I like that yeah like when you
guys do my podcast you will do it as
soon as you come to La I will wipe the
[ __ ] calendar clean for you guys
thank you thank you but um when are you
coming uh I think uh like the second
week of January you swear to God yeah
yeah you do mine of course after I'm
gonna I'm gonna call my guy and we're
gonna book it now for sure so anyway
um also like in the first level when you
come to my house um that's where the
podcast is for Tiger ballet so that's
communal it's a communal area people
people come and go people come and go
people are down there setting things up
this and that and then upstairs no one's
been up there like that yeah it's my
private residence so no shoes so you
would you go downstairs you can wear
your shoes upstairs don't wear your
shoes do you take your shoes off
upstairs as well
or you're okay it's my shoes yeah yeah I
like to do whatever I want I like that
that's pretty but I do go to a but you
know I do go to a spa three or four
times a week not what Steam and we yeah
go to the Wii spa or I'll go to Hyundai
my dad's that's about that my dad used
to go to back in the 80s you know I go
there so I'll go three or four times a
week and I go religiously at one two in
the morning and I take a steam and I
shower and I go to the hot sauna and all
that stuff I call cold plan it's Korean
it's very Korean yeah
I always love you guys to come I want to
get in this [ __ ] Sonic hole plunge
[ __ ] Rhythm everybody's doing I go to
one not right over the bridge in Jersey
it's called SoJO or Soju it's Korean
right I heard about it yeah it's been
nice got a beautiful view of the city
big outside 24 hours right I believe so
yeah yeah yeah and you walk in right
away the first thing you do before you
pay they go give me your shoes I think
you're walking around in [ __ ] nice
slippers the whole time yeah yeah is
that right how much does it cost to get
in there that's cheap it's like 70 bucks
for the day or something wow yeah like
at one in the morning you pay 40 bucks
you use at the facilities it's like
there's a communal area so I bring girls
there
so like they have a cruel department and
then and a boys department where you get
naked and you see big black dicks
there's always these black guys that
with big dicks and it drives me crazy
anyway um it just drives me crazy I
think it's so long they're long I know
but anyway
um but then I'll go it's driving me
crazy right yeah I'll tell the girl I'll
go meet me up there 20 minutes and then
you go up there and there's like things
that you can do with them like yeah you
know it's so fun you got a lounge you
can do this room that room type thing I
love it you know and I think that I
don't know that's classic it's real
classy and also I honestly think that
when you go to like a hot like Asana and
then you go to a cone plunge and you
repeat that I think it it generates
blood flowing through your body yeah
yeah I think I don't know medically what
it's doing but I feel better when I do
it sure it invigorates you I invigorates
you yeah yeah and for fat guys they
should do it yeah
[Applause]
listen I gotta be honest
I know we're getting down to the wire
here I'm kind of a coin flip I think I'm
on the fence here he's walking in both
worlds I mean
okay he would try to hem his own suit
with electrical tape okay here's the
dude here's the deal
I'll just make it very easy for you guys
to make a decision if I'm not garbage
I'll never do this again
this guy's truck have you ever been in a
car have you ever been on a cruise no
hmm
how many times a week do you floss I've
never flocked in my life okay I'm gonna
say this too check this out
you're not gonna believe this and I'll
show you after the [ __ ] podcast
but
from here back upper there's not a
single teeth but here back not a single
tooth there's chunks of teeth I probably
have 18 teeth missing
okay you win buddy
this guy's trash and we love you you're
missing 18 teeth I really am I'll show
you after you're not gonna believe it
I'll show you enough the cameras don't
pick it up ready yeah look down here
yeah yeah there's nothing nothing he's
just got he's got like four and let me
say something to you people right you
can still choose steak with no teeth it
hurts
bad I don't care how old that wagyu is
it hurts yeah it hurts bad yeah ladies
and gentlemen Mr Bobby Lane
100. so um Bobby Lee live Instagram
please follow me follow me on Twitter I
have two podcasts tigerbelly and bad
friends and um and also I I want to say
this that um honestly I really do love
you guys like I said before thank you
man and um let's just keep in touch and
I of course and I believe you're better
than Schultz and I think
we love you Chelsea
I love those guys Kevin what do you got
guys we'll be all over the road get the
tickets check out uh you know the live
shows everything patreon whatever you
want Bobby's [ __ ] crazy we love you
peace goodbye